oncólogo un diputado y un general del
ejército son los ministros que han
abandonado la cartera de salud en brasil
desde el comienzo de la pandemia ahora
el designado es el presidente de la
sociedad brasileña de cardiología
marcelo quiroga quien estará al frente
de un área clave en medio de una
situación crítica por la pandemia usted
ya lo conocía de hace algunos años
entonces no es alguien a quien acabe de
conocer en mi opinión tiene todo para
hacer un buen trabajo continuando con lo
que pasó él lo ha hecho hasta hoy todos
los festivos en general eduardo para
suelo era hasta la tarde del lunes el
ministro de salud e incluso anunció el
pedido de 138 millones de dosis de facer
y johnson and johnson el propio para
suelo reconoció que su salida era
posible aunque desde el gobierno no ha
habido en ninguna explicación clara
puede ser a corto mediano o largo plazo
el presidente está en este intento de
reorganizar el ministerio de vida
solo la semana pasada el gigante
sudamericano acumuló una cifra de
fallecidos por encima de la de cualquier
otro país en el mundo con balances
diarios que superaron los 2 mil decesos
al día pero desde el gobierno han
existido en mantener en marcha la
economía promoviendo tratamientos con
hidroxi cloroquina cuestionada por la
comunidad científica a nivel regional
ejecutivos como el del estado de sao
paulo el más grande de brasil con 46
millones de habitantes hacen caso omiso
a la línea del gobierno el gobernador
optó por permitir desde este lunes el
funcionamiento solo de los negocios
esenciales además de un toque de queda
entre las 8 de la noche y las 5 de la
mañana hasta el 30 de marzo